(upbeat electronic music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I'm Rhett.
- And I'm Link.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're asking the question, how was London?
- How was it?
- And then we're answering
that question 'cause as
of the recording of this,
we are still pretty fresh off of our trip
to London, England, United Kingdom,
Europe world.
- Not for long. (chuckles)
Yeah I still have jet lag.
- I still am, well--
- Are you waking up?
I'm waking up like--
- It is eight hours ahead--
- Three o'clock.
- Of us.
- I'm waking up like 3 a.m.
and I'm like ready to go
and then I'm like don't,
you gotta go back to sleep.
- Well the thing that I'm noticing is
at about seven o'clock at night--
- It hits you.
- I get hit really hard
with this irritability that,
like I was out to dinner with the family
and they were all
talking about interacting
with one another, which I mean,
if that's your thing.
- Yeah, your family's talking.
- It was not my thing
at the time, I mean, I
stopped at one point,
I was like guys, I just wanna tell you,
we're like halfway through the meal--
- I am so irritable right now.
- I just feel like I could
explode with irritability
and I'm just like very testy.
- You know, this is kinda crazy.
'Cause you know how it's
manifested itself with me?
Extreme restless legs.
- Really?
- Extreme restless legs.
Now I have restless legs
(grunts) syndrome.
(Link grunts)
I think I've talked about
this before, but anyway,
it's the irresistible urge to
move and what was happening is
it was in my right leg, it
started getting in my right hand.
- Well hold on, this is only
when you're sleeping, right?
- No, it happens when,
it happens typically
when you're trying to go to sleep
but what was happening
which was so weird is that
because of the jet lag, it was
hitting me about 7:30 for me,
so on Monday night I was
in my therapy appointment,
and I started having it real bad
and my leg was bouncing up and down
and I've never had it in my arm
and so my arm was also like,
I was moving around a lot.
And my therapist was like,
you're very uncomfortable
with what we're talking
about right now, aren't you?
And I was like, well, I mean yeah
but it's because I got
restless legs, brah.
- In my arm.
You got restless leg in your arm.
Why not call it restless arm?
- I don't know what that
is and then the next night,
I went back to my therapist
with my wife, it's a long story.
- Well let's go into it.
(Link chuckles)
- We just needed an emergency session.
- Okay.
- It was actually great.
Incredible session, but
during that, it happened again
and I was, just thinking about it--
- Show me exactly what you were doing.
- Like you see my foot?
You see my foot?
My foot would be out like
this and I'd be like--
- Okay your foot's out, so
you're just waggling your foot.
But what about your arm?
Okay you got a fist, you
got one hand in a fist
and you're grabbing it
with your other hand.
- Just moving.
- You just look
very uncomfortable.
- Yeah I look like
I'm squirming my way out of something,
and maybe I was--
- Yeah like when you get sent
to the principal's office
but you have to wait outside
and everyone's walking by going to lunch
and they see you sitting there.
- Yeah.
- And you're like,
his leg's twitching and he's
holding hands with himself.
- Just to be clear 'cause
a lot of people think,
oh I tap my leg a lot, I must have,
that's not restless leg syndrome.
So if you have a tendency
to let out excess energy
by bobbing your knee
up and down like that,
not restless legs, not the same thing.
Restless legs is this,
you only can explain it
if you have it, it's
this irresistible urge
to move to the point that you
feel like you're going to,
it's so uncomfortable not to move.
So it's not like the little thing
where you're just
bobbing up and down and--
- Well you know what--
- Don't wish it
on your worst enemy.
- I'm sorry you have that, Rhett.
- Okay, go ahead though.
- I don't have it.
Never experienced it.
I mean I'm only imagining
what it would be like
just by hearing you describe it.
- Right and I describe
it in such a vivid way.
You don't even need to
watch the video version
of this podcast in order to get all the,
of course, maybe you
do because I did a lot,
a lot of physical things a second ago.
Pretty impressive.
- (chuckles) Well you shook your foot
and that wasn't even in the shot.
- (laughs) But you saw it.
They can see your face looking at me.
- Yeah, they can.
Why are you yawning, man?
See, it's hitting you.
- I'm tired, man.
- Jet lag, dude.
- I'm from London.
I'm on London time.
- Once I told them I was about
to explode with irritability,
then it actually helped and
I didn't, for the record.
- Yeah, separated yourself from it.
You are not your emotions.
- But, they seemed to not have heard me.
It wasn't like they responded, it's like,
oh, thanks for sharing.
They could have said that.
- Yeah.
- They just kept talking,
but it made me feel good
to acknowledge that I had feelings instead
of letting those feelings control me.
- Yeah.
- That's what I'm actually
trying to do and it was nice to know
that it was jet lag and
that I'm not just a jerk
that doesn't wanna be around
my family, because I do.
- Yeah 'cause I thought
something was wrong with me,
it was so intense and
it was just the, no, no,
you would be asleep
right now and you're not.
- Yeah because 7 p.m.
feels like, let's see,
plus eight--
- 3 a.m.
- Is 15 a.m. which is 3 a.m.
There's no 15 a.m.
1500 hours would be 3 p.m.
- Right.
- There's no 15 a.m.
- You just, the next day--
- You know,
we should change that.
- They should just keep counting.
They should count from
the beginning of time.
- So we're going (chuckles)--
- That should be what time it is.
- We've never been to London
so this podcast is gonna be us
sharing with you our first
ever experience in London
except for being at the
airport, I mean we've been,
we've connected through the London airport
but we've never been
in the land of London,
like out and about.
- Yeah.
- So we're gonna share
those things with you.
We were there for VidCon
and also for a concert
that we played which was at the same venue
but was technically, well
it was a part of VidCon
but it was a separate
event, separate ticket.
- It's a little complicated
but doesn't matter
'cause it's done.
- It's over.
And I was just looking at the
pictures from the concert.
I was like man, that's really--
- Cool pictures.
- Really validates
having done it when you have
cool lookin' pictures of it.
- [Rhett] Well we got
some pictures taken by,
was it Anieck, is that how you, yeah.
- Thank you, Anieck.
- Anieck, Mythical Beast--
- For doing that.
- From Amsterdam.
Came over and took some pictures of us.
She took a lot of pictures
and then she sent us
what she deemed to be the cool
ones and they are very cool.
Posted one to my Instagram.
- So lots of thoughts
about London.
We'll get into all that but first,
I just wanted to share a story with you,
something that happened to
me that I haven't shared
when I got back from
London, so a few days ago,
I injured myself.
- Oh I'm surprised.
(Link chuckles)
- I just thought I
would share it with you,
loyal Ear Biscuit
listener, and to you Rhett,
loyal friend and irritable companion.
- Yep.
- So I get home and I happen
to mention to Christy,
I was like I'm gonna put my passport away.
I'm gonna put it back in the safe.
I keep my passport in our fireproof safe,
which ultimately I just
think if there was a fire,
I guess we'd grab the
safe but if we didn't,
maybe it would survive, but I don't know.
It's like--
- It's fireproof, man.
- It's fireproof
to a certain degree.
- Why you gotta grab it?
- That's true, I wouldn't
grab it, it's heavy.
It's a lot of things as I'll get into,
and she was like oh, get my passport too
because I haven't put mine back in there.
I was like well we need
to keep 'em in there.
- Yeah yeah.
- So I go get hers,
and the safe is not in the
place that it used to be.
- Well don't tell us where
it's at because I'll break in
and get it.
- I have to tell you.
- Okay.
- 'Cause what's more important
is me telling the story
than keeping secret
where my secret safe is.
- I got a dummy safe.
I got a safe that they'll take
and then think that they got the safe.
- Where is that one?
- I'm not gonna tell ya.
- Where's the real safe?
- Ha ha, definitely not telling you that.
- Oh you didn't fall for it this time
but you had already told me
that it's under your bed.
(both chuckles)
Isn't it?
- My safe can't fit under my bed, bro.
- You got a big safe?
- Yeah.
- Like how big
is your dummy safe?
I've seen your dummy
safe, it's like you walk
in the front door
and it's right there.
- You could carry it.
But the real safe I can get into.
- What?
- I've never told you about it.
- The dummy safe is in
the front of your house
just sittin' there.
A thief walks in, you're
like dummy safe here.
Wocka wocka wock--
- It says take me.
- I'm dummy.
I'm not a dummy safe.
- It says free.
- You have a walk-in safe?
- I might.
Let's talk about you gettin' hurt.
- Ironically a walk-in safe is not safe.
'Cause you can get locked in it.
- Well I'm not plannin'
on locking myself in.
- My safe is pretty
small, it's like the size
of four Trapper Keepers
stacked on top of each other.
It's got a lid on it.
Anyway, it's not in the
place that it used to be
and neither is Jade's dog kennel.
Jade is here with me today.
Jade, say hello.
I'm tellin' a story about
your kennel, your cage.
I don't like to call it a
cage because it's her home
when we're not at home and she likes it.
It makes her feel secure to go in there,
and more importantly she
doesn't pee or poop in it.
- Oh so you still put her
in her crate when you leave.
- Oh yeah because she will
pee and poop in the house.
She's part dachshund
and then she's the part
that likes to sneak and pee.
Anyway, when Britton moved into our house,
we converted the office into his bedroom.
- Right.
- Glorified closet.
Anyway, that's where we kept her kennel
and where I also kept the
safe and I kept the printer.
So then I'm like, I gotta find a new place
to put our printer.
I moved all of that stuff
that's in that bigger room
that he now sleeps in into
the closet that's underneath
the stairs that lead up to my bedroom.
So picture like a Harry
Potter kinda closet.
You open the door to that closet,
there's a light switch in there.
- Why didn't you just
put Britton in there?
- I thought about it.
I did think about it, I was like hey,
if it's good enough for Harry--
- Yeah, give him something
to write a song about.
(both chuckle)
- Have you been in this closet?
You open the door,
you hit a light switch--
- I didn't know it was there.
Next time I'm going in though.
- When you open the
door, you're looking down
the staircase that it goes,
if you look straight ahead
once you open the door,
it goes away from you
to, it slopes down to a point,
so you're not looking at it sideways
where it's sloping sideways.
You're at the tallest point
and then it's sloping down
to the floor.
- When you open the door.
And a matter of fact, it kinda slopes down
and then there's like a
cubby hole that I put,
stop yawning while I'm telling a story.
- It's boring, man. (chuckles)
- I know you're jet lagged
but it's not good for my ego.
- Your story's boring. (chuckles)
- So it slopes down and it--
- You're talking about
the architecture of this
under the stairs room.
Is it important?
- The architecture's important
to what happened.
- Okay.
- So you need to be
able to visualize this.
You walk in, it's about six feet tall,
it immediately slopes down to
about two and a half feet tall
where there's a cubby hole
that I put the printer in.
- Oh that's nice.
- Then in front
of the printer, I put the safe.
- In front of the printer.
- It's just a small safe.
Four Trapper Keepers, then to the right,
there's enough room for a book shelf
that has all of our board
games that we used to keep
in Britton's room.
- Oh.
Board games.
- So you can walk in
and get to the printer or
the safe or the board games.
- You don't put the board
games in the safe, huh?
- No, not enough room, I
don't have a walk-in safe.
I could make this whole closet a safe.
- I got all my board
games in my walk-in safe.
(chuckling)
- Chutes and Ladders is very flammable.
- Yeah, it's vintage edition.
- It would be easy to get to
the printer and to the safe
except for the fact that
then at the last minute,
I realized I didn't know
where to put Jade's crate
so then I put it in right
smack dab in the middle.
And it fills basically the
whole floor of the closet.
So when I go in there
to put the two passports
that are in my hand into the safe--
- You gotta move the crate.
- But moving the crate is difficult
'cause it's almost the width of the door.
- You gotta move the crate to print?
- Yeah.
Well--
- This is not sustainable.
But--
- What you can do is
you can basically, I can
stand in front of the crate
and bend over, like hinge,
then put my hand on the crate
or somewhere and then kinda reach
and grab what I've printed.
That's worked a few times.
- Easy.
- But the printer's a
foot higher than the safe.
I didn't take into account this
was gonna be more difficult
so I'm standing there, my
shin's against the front
of Jade's crate, then I hinge over
and I realize, I can't reach
the safe so what I do is,
I take my hand and I extend
it out as far as I can
and when the slope goes down,
it then goes vertical for a two by four
and then goes horizontal
into the cubby hole
where the printer is, so there's
a little two by four height
where--
- You rested your hand on.
- I rested my hand on that
and I'm pushing hard,
holding up my body weight
with my right hand and
then, I'm reaching down
with my left hand to open the safe.
And I realize, well, I can't open the safe
with my left hand 'cause I've got--
- My left hand doesn't know
the combination. (chuckles)
Only my right hand does.
- Well there's no combination on my safe.
It's just for fire.
It's not for theft.
All you gotta do is push, grab the handle,
push down on the safe.
- You don't have a combination?
- No, squeeze the handle,
and then it will open.
- My scans my eye before I walk in.
- I don't care.
- That's not true but you know.
- So then I'm like, I gotta switch hands
so then I gotta get my
right hand down there
because the safe handle's
on the right side and so,
I put my left hand up there
and I take my right hand down,
so now I'm--
- Always maintain
important contact.
- So now I am,
my whole upper body
weight is being held up
with my left hand and then I reach down,
again, I have the passports
in my hand but then
with my other three fingers,
I'm gonna grab the handle,
push down on the safe,
pick it up all the way,
open the lid and then I'm
going to throw the things in
and then I'm gonna close the lid
and then I'm gonna unhinge myself
and I'm gonna get out of
there like a proud man.
That's not how it happened.
(Rhett sputters)
So I'm holding myself up with my left hand
and I reach down to
grab the, open the safe,
and I open the safe and
as the lid is coming up
and I'm trying to pull the lid up,
my left hand slides--
- Yeah.
- Off of the two by four
that's holding my entire body weight up--
- Into the cubby.
- Yeah, and it goes into
air and then I just,
I start falling, so the
lid is up on the safe,
my hand is in a free-fall, my body begins
to be in a free-fall forward and the lid,
my right hand starts to fall
too and I try to catch myself
with my right hand 'cause
it's, I let go of the safe
and I turned my hand around to put my palm
toward the ground and catch myself,
but as I do that, the lid
of the safe comes down
on my fingertips--
- I think I see the finger
that got the brunt of it.
- And then the lid snaps
shut on my fingertips
while my left hand comes
down on top of the safe
and pushes my entire body weight on top
of the safe lid, thereby
smooshing completely
my middle finger.
And I'm not just saying
the tip, I'm saying just,
it clamped down just below
the base of the finger.
- So basically the whole top part above
that knuckle was safe from fire.
- Yes, it was, that is the
positive spin on this story.
The negative spin was that
I was in excruciating pain
where I had--
- Say any wordy dirds?
- I had locked my middle finger--
- It locked?
- Of my right hand
into the safe and was
applying my full body weight
on top of it and I was
in like a yoga position
that you just can't magically hinge up.
You just can't magically,
like my feet are way back here
behind the kennel.
- The fire safe position.
- I was--
- Dad's doing fire safe.
- I was like bent over a barrel basically.
And I don't know, at that
point I'm like struggling
to get my finger out of the
safe and it won't come out.
I'm like (grunts).
I wasn't--
- Were you home alone?
- I was not saying English,
I was not saying expletives,
I was grunting like a
caveman in pain, agony,
and just total despair
(chuckles) that I was
gonna be there forever.
- But how soon after
that kinda thing happens,
like in the middle of
it, are you thinking,
I'm gonna talk about this on Ear Biscuits?
(chuckles) Because--
- It hurt so bad.
- That's what happens to me now.
Anything that happens that is like,
I shouldn't have got
myself into this situation.
- Well I'll answer that because,
yeah what happened was, it
was an excruciating amount
of pain and of course time
slows down at that point
but somehow, I was able
to hop my left hand
off of the safe onto the floor
and then rip my right hand--
- Ugh.
- Out of the safe.
- It was still closed though?
- It didn't fully latch.
That would have been impossible.
And then, I put both my
hands on the dog crate
and peeled myself back.
- Well you could have
had trouble there too,
putting all your weight on the dog crate.
- Yeah and then--
- It'd collapse
the whole thing.
- And then I don't know
if I immediately laid down
on the floor or did a
dance around the room,
but I looked at the
footage and you could hear,
'cause I have that security
camera in that room.
But I was out of frame
but I played it back
and I could hear the noise I made.
It was like (grunting dramatically).
(pained grunting)
- [Christy] What's wrong?
What's wrong?
What did you do?
- [Link] My finger.
I squeezed it into my finger. (laughing)
(groans loudly)
(tape fast forwards)
(pained laughing)
- [Christy] You're doing
something in there.
What are you doing?
- [Lando] Is it hurting?
Are you hurting?
- [Christy] He's hurting
and he's trying to laugh
at the pain away.
(Rhett chuckles)
- And then I was like
(groans dramatically).
- Did you save that?
Did you save that clip?
- I got the clip, yeah.
If it works we'll throw it in there.
And I'm like, while I'm laying
on the ground like (grunts),
and like Christy comes
in there, she's like,
what's wrong?
She told me later she thought
that I'd fallen down the stairs.
(Rhett laughs)
It's like the noises
you make when you are--
- Your reaction--
- Falling down the stairs.
- You must have fallen
down the stairs, no,
let me explain what I did,
it'll take 12 minutes.
- I would have been (chuckles), yeah,
I would have been falling
except I was laughing
and I was thinking about
how ridiculous this was
and that I was gonna share
it with you on Ear Biscuits
at that point.
She got me some frozen peas
and she was like what happened?
And I was like, I smooshed
my finger in the safe.
I can't tell you the details
because I feel kinda faint right now.
And I was thinking about what had happened
and I started to feel
faint and I sat there
on my butt with frozen peas on my finger
for like 10 minutes
before I could feel like
I could stand up.
- You thought you might
have broken it maybe.
- Well I was convinced that
like I had lost my fingertip
or at least the nail.
And I still may lose the nail.
Oh man it hurt.
It still hurts a little but but,
oh man, I am so appreciative of nails.
- You know what's kinda
interesting as well--
- If it wasn't for fingernails, yeah,
I would have lost the fingertip.
I think it's a protect, it's armor.
- I'm not gonna tell the story
'cause it's not much of a
story but you know the finger
that I hurt before we left for London?
I was telling you about
putting my hand into my
guitar case and the thing
going between my fingernail.
- Oh yeah.
- It was the same
finger, the middle finger
of the right hand.
- The right hand.
- It's been swollen, see that?
- You think this is a sign or something?
- It's been swollen ever since,
it's like I was worried that--
- You talking about the cutilage,
the cuticle on the right side of your--
- Yeah this thing went in and it bled.
It went down in there and then bled.
- I did that one time and it got infected.
- That's what I thought was happening.
- And it swelled up so big
that I super heated a needle
underneath a flame and I stuck it in
to drain all the puss out.
- I thought I was gonna get
some sort of London bacteria.
You know like some old world bacteria
that was gonna take me out.
I don't know how bacteria works.
Okay, we're both fine though.
- Well I'm not fine, my
fingertip still hurts, brother.
- Okay, we are gonna talk about London,
but first, we are going to
talk about Link's shirt.
He has--
- Oh wow.
- The brand new Apawcalypse
collection shirt,
well it's a whole collection.
There's a whole story behind
this, this collection.
This is something new that we're doing
where we're doing a
collection of clothing--
- It's called storywear.
- Storywear.
- You don't want someone
to wear stuff that's logos.
You wanna wear something
that tells a story.
- So there's a story, by the
time you're hearing this,
I'm sure that the trailer
for the story's gonna be out.
In fact, I just recorded the
VO for it so hopefully it's out
and this is going to be something that,
we're trying it and seeing how this goes
but we have--
- It's awesome.
- An artist who kinda created
all this incredible stuff
that fits this theme about
a post apocalyptic world
in which dogs have kinda taken over and--
- Apawcalypse.
- Humans are the pets and
it's really cool stuff
that just says Mythical on it somewhere.
- I'm very excited about the pants.
- Yeah--
- We got some camo.
- Some camo sweats.
- Very comfortable, so rep
all of that, Mythical.store.
Check it out, we also have an Amazon store
where we got stuff over
there, so, rep ya boys.
- Okay let's talk about London.
- Like we said we had
never been to London.
The thing that I'm really into
are the little differences.
I thought maybe we could
start with just a couple
of the little differences that we noticed.
- Well there's the thing
that you talked about
at the beginning of our concert
that you were fascinated with.
- When you stop at a traffic light
and it's 'cause the light's red,
that also means in London
that you need to stop
even though you're driving
or riding on the other side
of the road, when you see a
red light you should stop,
but once you're stopped,
when it's time to go,
the light just doesn't turn green, people.
It turns yellow to warn
you to give you a head's up
that it's about to turn green
and then it turns green.
So it turns yellow on both sides of a red.
Warning, you're about to stop.
Yellow, red, and then head's up,
you're about to get to go again.
Yellow, green.
And I never heard of this.
I just thought this would
be something that they say
about London, this seems important to me.
- I think it's that
way in other places too
other than just London, but--
- I've been to other
places, never seen it.
I don't deny that it could happen.
- The reason it's not other
places, it's unnecessary.
- I love it.
- It's unnecessary.
- I love it, I'm a planner, man.
I like to know when
something's gonna happen.
And specifically when it comes to driving,
I like to be the guy who
takes my foot off the brake
and I like--
- I understand.
- Start to give it a little gas.
- But here's why it's unnecessary,
because it flashes for such
a short period of time,
less than a second.
Your action that you take
after you see the yellow
is the same action that
we here in America take
when we see green.
- But psychologically--
- There's no difference though,
there's no active difference.
- There's definitely a
psychological difference
because it's, if the light's
green and I'm not going,
I feel like a failure.
So I feel like I have no
chance of being a success
unless I start going,
risking going when it's red
which is unsafe and a violation.
- I'm not looking for emotional support
from the way I respond to traffic lights.
- The Brits give me an
opportunity to feel like a success
when driving and I like it
because I wanna be in motion.
- But do you think that
when they made the decision--
- When it's green.
- To do this in Parliament
or wherever they made the
decision, they were like--
- We were yelling about it.
- We want people
to feel like a success, no, they think,
they have a traffic reason
for why this is the case.
There's no other way--
- You're a civil engineer.
What do you think it is?
Like walk a mile in their shoes.
- The reason that, from
an engineering standpoint,
and I haven't thought about this much
so I could definitely be
wrong, let me just state that.
So I am open to hearing
the engineering argument
for this but the reason that--
- Can we loop that part where you say
I could definitely be wrong.
- They can loop it if they want.
- I'm just inviting them to
loop that, like GIF it, GIF it.
- The reason that the
yellow light is in between
the green and the red
is because there's a lot
of variables, there's so many variables
while all the cars are moving.
- Sure.
- Where you're at,
how fast you're going.
- Sure.
- So there's a decision to be made, right?
There is no decision,
it's a binary decision
that needs to be made 'cause,
how fast am I gonna slow down,
am I gonna go through the light, am I not?
There's only one decision
that you can make
when the light turns green
and that is to accelerate,
to go and so by seeing the
yellow light for a split second,
the outcome is the same, it's unnecessary.
It's not needed, it doesn't do anything
'cause people are responding
to it the same way
that we respond to a green light.
- The thing that I read
about it is that it's related
to stick shifts because if you're not,
to get in the right gear,
it's just another head's up
'cause you have to,
there's preparatory work.
I'm not making this up,
this is something that I happened to read.
- I understand that and
there's many more manual cars
in England than there are in America.
- And I only drive manual.
- But here's my thing.
- That's a lie.
But I do like to--
- If we're all,
I guess okay, all right, so--
- We don't need to camp
out, we don't need to--
- It's not up there long enough,
because that's not a bad reason because,
'cause now there's a variable.
If you've got half of the
people in line have manuals
and half of the people have automatics,
the people who have automatics
are theoretically going
to be able to start that much sooner,
so therefore maybe the
length of the yellow light
is the average time that
it takes for someone
to get into the right gear and go,
to get in first gear and go.
- Now I would also say that you could also
already be in first gear like
we do in America and wait so,
the reason why I like it
is a reason I already gave.
It's emotional, it's psychological
so there's no argument
here, it's fascination only.
- Well the thing that I pointed out
at the beginning of the
concert as well is that
the urinals, there's a few
differences in the bathroom
we'll talk about one of the
differences in the bathrooms
and the men's bathrooms
is that the urinals
and I'm assuming that's
what they call them as well,
on the wall which you pee into.
You can poop into 'em, I--
(Link sputters)
I have in an emergency.
- I think they call 'em loo holes.
The bathroom's called a loo so.
- Nowhere anywhere was there a divider
between the urinals and now it is not,
it's not that there's
only dividers in the U.S.
But there's dividers in most places.
- At least 50%.
I did not encounter one urinal divider.
- And they're pretty close to each other
so it's kinda like, I don't
necessarily have a problem
with it but I don't feel
completely comfortable.
- You know what I think it is?
They don't talk, they don't
have smalltalk with strangers.
That's something that doesn't happen,
like it happens some in America,
people will strike up a
conversation with somebody
just out and about.
- Do you think that's the case?
You just went to one city
for a couple of days.
- I read about this.
- Oh.
You've been reading.
- I just wanted to validate
what I thought were
the differences and I just
happened to find that out,
they don't have smalltalk
on like the tube, you know.
- It's weird for them
to speak to strangers--
- Now in New York, I mean, on the subway,
I don't see people talking to each other,
but I think maybe there's
a higher likelihood
that Americans will shoot the breeze
at adjacent urinals if there's no divider.
But the Brits don't have
to worry about that.
- I've had a number of people
strike up a conversation
with me while I was urinating.
- In London though?
- No, definitely no London.
- Not in London.
But if there was a divider--
- That is not my preferred
communication--
- No, I don't like,
I don't even talk to--
- I don't even turn my head.
I will not respond--
- Myself, I don't talk
to myself at a urinal.
- No, definitely.
- You don't wanna be at a
urinal muttering to yourself.
That's not a good look.
- So they don't have dividers.
They also don't have paper towels.
- That's good on them, lot of hand drying.
- And this was the case
in Amsterdam as well.
- And in Australia.
- There may be a--
- I think everybody else
has figured out that we
don't need to dry our hands
on trees except for us.
- But is it really better
for the environment?
Because you're using electricity which
in most places is still
the majority of electricity
is being produced by fossil fuel burning,
so I guess once we go all renewable,
it definitely makes sense.
It has been proven that
they're not as sanitary though,
I think.
Don't quote me on that but I think
that they did a study
that the hand dryers,
even though sometimes they
say it's more sanitary,
it's not more sanitary
because it's blowing bathroom air around.
Bathroom air is little
pieces of pee and poop, man.
- A lot of them have that
Dyson where you like,
it's that small slot
that you gotta totally
get your flat hands in and then--
- Air blade--
- It opens up a little bit
on an air blade and then you're
slowly pulling your hands
back out but it's nerve-wracking, man,
because you feel like you're
so close to the plastic parts
that everybody's, it's so close to.
- And not only that.
What happens on the way out?
- Of what?
- You touch the handle.
You don't have a paper towel.
You can't do the perfect bathroom trip
without a paper towel.
- We wrote a whole song about this.
♪ Then retain it ♪
♪ For the doorknob may be tainted ♪
♪ As you exit, bank it off the wall ♪
♪ Into the trash can ♪
♪ It's the perfect bathroom trip, man ♪
- The paper towel is for opening the door.
- We still use that
instrumental at the end
of our Ear Biscuits.
- We do?
- Perfect Bathroom Trip
is the outro.
- Wow.
That is what that is, isn't it?
♪ It's a perfect bathroom trip ♪
- So you can't have a
perfect bathroom trip
in England because you're going to end up
contaminating yourself on the door handle
no matter how well it goes.
- I think you can use your shirt sleeve.
- Or your own hanky or your foot.
But you open up with your
foot, now everybody decides
to open it up with their
hand has been compromised.
- Did you feel like the
hotel was different?
- Definitely.
We stayed at the hotel that was
right there at the venue, at the ExCeL.
- Mm-hmm.
- So I've stayed at this brand of hotel
in the U.S. and listen,
I'm about to sound like
a spoiled brat, fine, whatever.
- I think we already do.
- Deal with it.
- We are spoiled.
We sound like it all the time.
Just keep it rollin'.
- While we're talking about differences,
I'm gonna tell you, the
sheets were rough, man.
- The sheets were rough?
- The sheets felt like
a little bit, a little cardboardy,
and then the TP in the bathroom.
- I was gonna ask Jenna if she
thought the sheets were rough
but she works for us.
She puts up with us all the time.
She can probably put
up with a rough sheet.
Did you think the sheets were rough?
- Yeah you did, 'cause they were!
Now I slept fine.
- I didn't notice.
I didn't notice the sheets were rough,
but I'll tell ya what I noticed.
When I took a shower and
then I got that towel down
and I was drying off?
I dry off my face first
and I take a deep breath
and the freakin' towel smelled like ramen.
- They make towels out of ramen there.
(chuckles)
- I mean, if it got real damp,
it might woulda just turned
into a floppy noodle.
- But that might be an isolated thing
because I have a theory
about the rough toilet paper
and the rough sheets, again,
I've stayed at this kind
of hotel in the U.S.
and I do not remember this.
And again, I'm not saying
that it was intolerable.
I slept fine.
- I slept good.
- It's just the sheets
that I enjoy on my bed
and at the typical hotels that I frequent
in the United States of
America have very soft sheets.
It's just part of the deal.
- High thread count.
- And also,
they have quilted toilet
paper inside of the bathrooms.
I have quilted toilet
paper in my bathroom.
- So what's the theory?
- 'Cause I have, I want to
treat my butt hole well.
I mean that's what I do,
the kinda guy that I am.
I actually have a bidet. (laughs)
But then--
- You know I got a bidet.
I got a bidet for days.
- I just think that
something about, okay like--
- I could set the exact temperature of it.
- You have the history of--
- We're so pampered.
- You have the history
of the English people, you know--
- I could sear my own butt
hole with the temperature
of my bidet if I wanted to.
- Well, you don't do that,
that's not caring for your butt hole.
- Just like you just
wanna, when you're done,
you just want that thing--
- Do you wanna hear
the theory?
- To smoke.
- The theory is--
(Link hisses)
- Sizzle.
- That western Europe,
people...
It's a rough, it's a rough bunch, man.
I mean actually, like legitimately,
if you ever read Guns, Germs and Steel
which I have recommended
on this podcast before,
a lot of people ask why
is it that the people
from western Europe who
went to the New World,
why did they not die from the diseases?
Why was it the Native Americans that died
from the diseases that
the white people brought?
- Because they had rough
rectums, that's why.
- The reason is is because they
had lived in close quarters
and sort of this uncomfortable,
bacteria-laden lifestyle.
- Sewage on the--
- Sewage--
- On the bricks.
- And people on top of each
other, like if you go back
to old school western Europe
back in the Middle Ages,
it was dirty as, it was so crazy.
- Unapologetically steppin' on chickens.
- People dying all over the place,
and then you've got the
people in the New World,
the Native Americans who--
- Wide open spaces.
- Wide open--
- Pottery.
- They weren't living
on top of each other and so
you got these super viruses,
super bacteria that are
coming across on these boats
and then just decimating
the Native population.
I think that they just have this--
- Ruddiness.
- They've been,
it's just been rough, man.
And they like it rough.
(both chuckle)
They like the sheets rough,
they don't know that the sheets are rough.
But something about coming over to--
- We're soft.
- Coming over here and
starting a new nation
that's all about freedom.
(both chuckle)
You know it's like--
- Freedom!
(Rhett laughs)
Why you gotta say it like--
- We just got, we got ahead
of ourselves, you know?
We're like oh, you know what?
We can vote.
We don't have to have a king,
we could have a president.
And we got all, we all
got all high and mighty
about all our freedoms and
then next thing you know,
we got soft everything.
- I wanna wipe my butt
with a blanket.
- Right.
We wanted everything so soft.
And we got it and now we're spoiled.
- Oh we're spoiled.
- And they're like no
no, keep it rough, man.
And so actually, I envy them.
I envy them that they can take it rough.
They can take a rough sheet.
They can take a rough TP,
because my booty's adjusted.
It's like now I go over
there and I can't take it.
It's like I have to travel
with my own frickin' toilet paper,
'cause I'm just a, you
know, spoiled American.
- Yeah you're spending too much time
minding the wrong gap, you feel me?
- Yeah.
- I never saw that sign,
by the way, I never saw a
sign that said mind the gap.
I saw a sign that said Underground,
but they call it the tube.
- [Rhett] Yeah, we went on that.
- [Link] I think the Underground
is a pedestrian tunnel.
- While we're complaining about things--
- No a subway is a pedestrian tunnel.
- Now I'm gonna say I loved London.
Okay, let me just say that.
- But let's go back
to complaining now, 'cause you said it.
- That's where I'm gonna land.
- Oh gosh.
- I loved London.
I plan to go back.
But let me--
- We think it's funny
to complain.
- Let me just,
I'm just gonna complain a little bit more
'cause I do wanna talk about the food.
I feel I have to talk
about the food, okay?
(Link sighs)
Now let me just say, I know that,
again, not only are we
spoiled just as a culture,
we are spoiled above and beyond
because we live in Los Angeles.
- It's a good food place.
- And we just,
we have--
- Access.
- We can get some good food, y'all.
I go back, I go back to North Carolina
and it's gotten a whole
lot better than it was,
even when we moved away
but if you don't get up
in there in the Raleigh area,
you're not gonna get real good food.
- But--
- Now--
- No you're gonna get comfort food
that's comfortable
everywhere, reliably good.
I mean--
- I don't enjoy Golden Corral.
What I'm saying is that--
- Well.
- I just can't do it anymore.
- I know, I know.
- You can judge me all you want,
I just can't enjoy it anymore
because I've gotten too
big for my britches.
But what happens is is,
we go to London and we
just, well, you know what,
I'll let you take it from here
because you had some
choice opinions as well.
Why don't you tell 'em about--
- Well they...
It's the trope that the
food's not good in London,
and then they said, but
it's gotten a lot better.
And you know what--
- Could you imagine
what it was like?
- We went to this place.
We had to grab some lunch
and we're like, wanna split,
we end up going to this place
called Slug and Lettuce.
- (chuckles) Listen.
- It's a chain.
- We 'bout to--
- What on Earth?
- We 'bout to throw
Slug and Lettuce--
- Under the--
- Under the bus.
We're about to rip 'em--
- The double-decker bus.
- We about to rip 'em a new one
with the roughest toilet
paper you have ever,
ever felt on your rectum.
- Why on Earth would you name
a place Slug and Lettuce?
- Maybe it means something
different in English.
(both chuckle)
- And why on Earth would I suggest
after we saw like five places--
- You suggested it.
- Well because they had a menu
out front and it said they
had fish and chips on,
it was like, you know, we
need to eat like a British,
some food from Britain.
- Well and let us--
- I need to eat some
fish and chips.
- We need to premise
this with the fact that
we weren't really in
the main part of London,
where the ExCeL is, I don't know what part
of London we were in but--
- We were like 40 minutes
outside, we were in a suburb.
- Were were staying like,
we were in the Anaheim of London,
for those of you who are familiar
with the Los Angeles area.
Like if you go to Anaheim and
you're like I don't like LA,
well you haven't been to LA.
It's different, right, it's a suburb.
So where the ExCeL is
is not exactly London.
- Well and we took a gondola
across the landfill to--
- In the River Thames.
- Yeah to see,
to go in the O2 where they
had all these different places
where you could eat and
we're like perusing the menus
as you walk down the pathway.
I'm like, let's just eat here.
We're gonna grab and go something.
They got fish and chips
and they got salads
if you don't want that and I need
to eat some fish and chips.
- But the reason we didn't eat at,
there was also a Mexican place.
- There was a Mexican place,
there was an Italian place.
- But we have to tell a side story
before we call tell the
Slug and Lettuce story
because the reason we
didn't get the Mexican food
is because the night
before, we had been out,
in the main part of London,
we went to Shoreditch
and then we ended up going
to, Soho or somewhere,
I don't know where we went.
Anyway so, we were bar hopping basically,
going to these old English
bars that said things like
since 1529, which, that
was amazing to go into bars
that were that old.
We went to this really, really cool place
that was inside an old prison and the--
- Old jail, they had--
- Old jail.
- Yeah you go downstairs and
it was all this brick work
and they seated us in this room
that was an archway entrance
that then, it was one huge
table that had bench seating
the other left side and
the right side in the back,
just like a U seating and
the whole ceiling was like
a bricked in hanger,
it was like an archway.
- [Rhett] It was an old cell.
- Yeah, it was a old jail cell
and we didn't realize that.
- And we were like--
- Very cool.
We were hungry.
- We were getting some pints
but we wanted some food as well and so,
I was like, are you guys serving any food,
'cause it was late, it
was almost midnight.
I was like, you guys serving any food?
He says, "Um, yes, uh,
"we have, what do you call them?
"The small Mexican crisps."
(Link chuckles)
- And we all looked at each other
and you said--
- I was like, tortillas?
- He's like yes.
What he really was, tortilla chips.
And some salsa so--
- And then you were like, ooh yes, that.
- So he said I'll bring
you everything that I have,
he had some olives, he
had some pickles, he had,
again, this is a very cool place.
- Gherkins I think.
- But he brought
the Mexican crisps, the tortilla chips.
Now again, we're from Los Angeles.
We know what a frickin' tortilla chip is,
we probably can get some of
the best in the world, right?
- We're very close to the
place where there's lots of--
- The source.
- Mexico.
- And the tortilla chips were,
I mean they were tortilla chips.
They weren't absolutely horrible.
- They were small Mexican crisps.
- The salsa
was ketchup with onions in it.
It was ketchup with onions in it.
I mean that's the only way
that I can describe it.
It was ketchup with onions in it.
Now I ate two bowls of it 'cause I was--
- He did.
- I was very hungry.
- You ate everything.
- And I like ketchup
and onions, it's just, that's not salsa.
- I know, but, I mean you're in London.
Why are you ordering chips and salsa?
- It's all they had!
- It is all they had.
- So that's why the next day--
- It wasn't like we chose that.
It was like that's all that they--
- Right right.
- Everything they had we got.
- I was still having an incredible time.
I loved everybody, I loved
the scenery and how old--
- The drinks were great.
- The atmosphere was great.
The people were great.
- The people were great.
But then the next day, you were like
I wanna get some tradition, I
wanna get some fish and chips
and I was like, well
definitely don't wanna go
to the Mexican restaurant 'cause I'm not
in the mood for Mexican crisps.
- This was Valentine's Day.
I was in a sad place at that moment.
I wanted to be with my wife.
I didn't wanna be with you.
- Right.
- Eating
Mexican crisps at some arena.
- Yeah it was an arena, it was the O2.
- It was an arena.
- But you insisted on Slug and Lettuce.
- At least well they got fish and chips
and it looks British in there (chuckles).
Jenna picks up the menu and
she's like crinkle browed
and she's like, well there's
like 18 pages of drinks
and there's like one page of food.
This is just a bar.
- But there was a lot
of stuff on the menu
because at that point,
I had already made the
decision that I wanted
to get something healthy.
- I'mma get fish and chips.
- Regardless of how bad it is.
So I had a little issue
because I wanted the salmon
and the superfood salad, right?
- Oh gosh.
- But they had salmon with vegetables
and then they had the superfood salad
with this other meat
and so I went up there
to order at the bar and
I was like, so yeah,
I want the superfood salad
but instead of the steak,
I want the salmon.
He was like, oh we can't do that.
It was like I had asked to
walk out with something.
And he was like, we can't
do that, I was like,
you sure you can't just do the salmon?
- You might as well have said, you know,
I'd like to burn this place down.
- Yeah yeah and then he went and just,
I'll go ask my manager and
he goes and asks the manager
and I see him ask the
manager and the manager looks
at me and he's like.
Like what?
Like wha, okay.
Can't substitute, maybe
I've gotten spoiled
because you can substitute other meats in.
- Now at that point,
you weren't that spoiled
because at that point, what did you do?
- I ordered both.
(Link laughs)
I said okay then I'll
take the salmon with that
and then I'll take the superfood
side, the salad, whatever.
Give me both of 'em.
- The fish and chips just
to cut to the chase here,
were horrible.
I mean why come, the fish
and chips are horrible.
They were the blandest, tasteless,
I mean I'm sitting there
like pouring vinegar and
salt over the whole thing.
I mean I need a lot of salt
and they don't salt a lot of stuff.
I guess.
- Well no,
because--
- It just was so bad.
- Because we had good food
but at the Slug and Lettuce,
we might as well have
had a slug or lettuce.
- After our show,
we're devoting this whole freakin' podcast
to complaining about everything in London.
(Rhett hisses)
- We'll be back, guys.
- I feel horrible.
After the show, we're like, we can't go,
we're just gonna go back to the room,
we're gonna order room service.
We find out the hotel
doesn't have room service
at this time of night.
- Yeah, it's a night thing.
- So we're at the front
desk and we're like well,
can we order pizza?
He's like yes and he gives
us three different flyers
of where you can order pizza.
- Now no places that are,
no chains that I recognized.
And listen, it isn't like
I think that Domino's
and Little Caesars, et cetera,
Pizza Hut is the best pizza
in the world, I think,
but it's good pizza.
It's passable pizza.
- I will say that
we have come to appreciate it anew.
(Rhett laughs)
Because they delivered this pizza.
It was so bad, my wife loves pizza.
I had to put her on video
chat in order to show her
how sad this pizza was and it's a place,
it's a pizza delivery place.
- And let me tell you that
the guys at the front desk
at this hotel we were staying in
specifically pointed out this place.
They were like, we got
that the other night
and it was great.
And so I was like okay.
So, I think that that it's
us, you know what I'm saying.
It was awful.
I don't understand, listen.
Pizza is simple.
It's dough, it's sauce, it's
cheese and it's toppings,
and they failed--
- You don't have to tell 'em
what pizza it is.
- But they failed miserably
in all four categories.
- It was uncanny.
- I was like--
- How much of it did you eat?
- Five pieces.
(Link giggles)
But I did not enjoy it.
- You didn't enjoy it one bit.
- At all, it was just sustenance.
I was freaking tired after our
show and the meet and greet,
we hadn't eaten anything
in a very long time.
- Oh we were--
- So hungry.
- It's so sad.
- It was 2 a.m.!
But let's talk about the
food that we did enjoy
because I also had what
I consider to be one
of the top...
It's definitely top 20 meals
that I've had in a restaurant.
- I'll agree with that.
If you wanna get really good British food,
get Indian food.
(Rhett laughs)
We ate at this place Dishoom in Shoreditch
and people, this is like
a sit-down restaurant,
fancy cocktail drinks, all the Indian food
that you would expect
from an Indian restaurant
and so it's like a sit-down
meal, dining experience.
People are lined up
around the block waiting
for hours, people
probably wait three hours.
- Waiting to wait.
- Waiting to then put
their name in and wait.
- We waited an hour and a half
and we just had to have
one person there so--
- And it was worth, it was worth it.
It was so good, it was
like a magical experience
and I think that's the key.
You eat all this stuff
and it's just so bland
or unbelievably horrible
and then you just have,
you go to these dining experiences
and I think it's top 20.
It's either really great or
just really great by comparison.
But it was fabulous.
- But can you explain to me--
- It was so good.
- How, okay so, right okay.
Traditional English food has
a reputation for being bland.
Right, sort of meat and potatoes.
- Mushy peas.
- But then, one of the
countries that they imperialized
has incredible food and
they end up getting,
they end up getting that food
and now they kinda call it their own.
- Yeah.
- But if they like that food--
- They didn't mess it up.
- 'Cause Indian food--
- But why didn't they make
the other food better?
- Right Indian food is so
flavorful and so bright and like--
- It's, I think it may be
the best food on the planet.
- I think it might be my
favorite flavor combination.
- I mean we were gushing
about it for hours.
- Because okay, because
the other good meal we had
was the night before when we
went to that really old bar
that I think was founded in
1666 which I thought was cool.
- Oh we had some meat
pies, they were good.
- And we had a Guinness and
I had a venison meat pie
that was, oh and then
we got a little sampler,
they have like a Scotch
egg and some other things.
All--
- Great.
- Really, really really good.
- So you go to the right place,
you can get some good stuff.
- And that's like traditional stuff.
It was really good, it was like,
it just had the right flavor balance.
'Cause Stevie, Stevie got a
meat pie at Slug and Lettuce.
Do you remember what
that thing looked like?
- Oh gosh.
They should just call Slug on Lettuce
and that's what they should serve.
You go in, you're like,
you know what I want
'cause it's all that you serve.
I want a slug on a piece of
lettuce and you know what?
You will have a better
experience than we had.
- This episode of Ear
Biscuits is not brought to you
by Slug and Lettuce.
- We also had some great Thai food.
Very interesting Thai
food just catty corner--
- Oh.
- To Dishoom when we couldn't
get in the first night.
- Was that called The Smoking
Goat or something like that?
- Are we gonna talk about anything else
'cause let's switch
from the food, you know.
- Yeah yeah yeah yeah, let's, yeah.
So anyway, we had some good
food and we had some bad good.
- We took a walking tour, I
like to take a walking tour
when I'm new to a city,
I've said this before.
We took a walking tour, this one, well,
it happened to be a Jack
the Ripper walking tour.
Turns out, didn't know much about the guy.
He's a serial killer and so,
you probably already knew
that and I think I did
but I just didn't wanna dwell on it,
so I find myself walking around
the city and it is butt cold
and windy as all get out.
I'm like--
- We're a little underdressed too.
- A little underdressed.
And this woman is
walking us around saying,
"Oh look, here.
"A woman was disemboweled
and her throat was slit
"and then her innards were
thrown over her shoulders.
"And let's walk over here,
I got another story for ya."
- This woman's uterus was cut out.
- This woman, her throat was slit
and her innards were
thrown out of her body.
Hey now, let's keep walking.
I got a surprise.
Here's where a woman,
you'll never believe this.
A woman's throat was slit and
her innards were thrown out.
- Yeah that's what Jack did.
- Just keep walking.
And that just kept happening.
It was quite repetitive.
- And it kept getting colder
and colder.
- It was like,
it was like a serial walking tour.
It was like the same walking
tour again and again and again.
- And the theme of the night was,
we don't know who Jack the Ripper was.
But it might have been this guy.
It might have been--
- [Both] This guy.
- It might have been--
- This guy.
- And at the end she was like,
so, who do you think it was?
- And we were like (sputters),
I think wherever he is,
he's probably warmer
than me right now.
- I was just thinking does it matter?
(both chuckle)
I mean, does it really matter?
What we gonna go put him in jail?
(both laugh)
- We are horrible.
We are horrible walking
tour patrons because,
like when we did that walking--
- No I was being very nice though.
- The ghost tour in New Orleans,
we were not good patrons there.
- No but because that girl--
- That was not good.
- She was not doing
a good job but, this woman
was really good at her job.
- She was a Ripperologist.
- Ripperologist.
- That's a title you
can just give yourself.
- That's also someone who
uses U.K. toilet paper.
(both laugh)
- Gosh.
VidCon was a blast.
What I mean by that was, we did a Q and A.
Stevie asked us some questions submitted
by Mythical Beasts who were there.
I always have fun doing that.
'Cause the objective
is to throw Stevie off
of her game to like just
try to bring the audience
along for the ride, that was fun.
We did a meet and greet,
we got a press the flesh
with some fans, that's a political term
for just shake hands with people.
- Yeah you should probably
come up with a new one.
- And we had done our concert which,
I'm gonna watch the tape back.
I'm sure I'll have a lot of notes for us.
But in general, I had a really fun time.
I said it from stage, I was proud of you.
You sat there and you played your keyboard
for the first time.
- Did you, okay--
- Look at that.
- Speaking of that.
Now I've already told you that our,
you know, musical hero
John Mayer is learning,
you told me that he was
learning to play the piano
and I went on his Instagram
and saw that he was doing that.
Do you know who else is learning
to play the piano right now
and I just saw on his Instagram?
- John Legend.
He's been finger syncing this entire time.
- Nope.
Jimmy Fallon.
Jimmy Fallon is learning to play the piano
and--
- Very musically gifted too.
- It was like I am
learning to play the piano
and he's taking a course, an online course
that Harry Connick Jr. Teaches.
- Huh, really.
- And John Mayer commented
on Jimmy's post and said,
"I've got adult onset
piano fever as well,"
and I was like, hold up, so do I.
And John Mayer was born
five days after me.
- I love him.
- And Jimmy is a little bit older than us.
- I like him a lot too.
- Now John Mayer
commented on Jimmy's post.
I comment on Jimmy's post.
At this point in time, he's
responded to John Mayer.
- Okay.
- Hasn't responded to me
but you know, give him time.
But what is it?
- You want me
to get in the mix?
- Is there something
in the air, is there
something in the water?
- Is this Twitter or Instagram?
- This is Instagram.
- I'm on that.
Shout-out to LinkLamont on Instagram.
I'll get in the mix.
- It's just interesting that old,
old men are teaching themselves
how to play the piano.
- It's a mid-life crisis kinda thing.
- Definitely seems like it.
We had a great time at
the concert, thank you--
- It was fun.
- For all you who came.
- It did open things
up to play that piano.
- I wanna make an observation
about the crowd at VidCon.
Not the crowd in the crowd but
the other YouTubers, right?
- Not our people.
Not Mythical Beasts you're talking about.
I think I know where you're going.
- I'm talking specifically,
now I didn't know,
I didn't know many.
I didn't know any.
I've got like the
British YouTubers, TomSka
and Jack and Dean and
Dan and Phil, you know,
the people who've been
around for a really long time
that everybody knows about.
- I regret we didn't get
to talk to Jack or Dean.
- I spoke to Jack.
- Okay.
- Briefly.
- He said hello.
- To me?
- He didn't, but now I feel
bad 'cause you didn't talk
to him so just act, he said hello.
Just take it.
- To someone probably.
- But I noticed that now
there's the old school
like sketch guys that I
kinda know and understand,
but then there's like the new
school British vlogger, right?
Maybe they're European
in general, I don't know,
but I just noticed there
was like a uniform.
You know what I'm talking about?
- There's a lot of brow
threading, I noticed that.
- Well yeah, both the men
and the women pay a lot
of attention to their eyebrows
being very perfectly shaped,
but everyone's in athletic wear.
- Yes.
- Like cool matching sweats.
Like all the girls had these,
they looked like they were
about to go to the gym at
like a really nice resort
and they had their hair in ponytails.
They have a crap ton of makeup on.
- Oh goodness, yes.
- A crap ton of scent, perfume on.
- Yeah.
- And they look like
they're about to run like
a celebrity track meet thing.
- You know that filter on Instagram
that makes your face look
really fake and makeuppy?
They just do that in real life.
- Yeah but it's like everybody's
really well put together.
- Like an airbrushed face.
- And then the guys are--
- The same.
- Sorta the same thing
going on but like an athletic wear,
I mean look, I got a hoodie on.
You know, I'm ready to be
athletic at the drop of a hat.
- Is this a Ariana Grande type thing?
I think, you know with the
ponytail and the athletic wear.
She'll do that.
- Is that happening in
this country as well?
- Probably yeah.
- It's not something that I'm,
I don't observe the young people anymore.
I just look over them.
- You look through your own kids, right?
- Right, I have noticed
that our kids are doing
the athletic wear thing but it's a--
- But they take it to
another level and it's like,
it's like if your backup dancers were all
wearing athletic wear,
you know it's like that,
it's a heightened type thing.
It's heightened.
- Yeah.
- And then you get,
you're on an elevator and
then the doors are closing,
all of a sudden it's like, oy, oy, oy!
And then all of a sudden
the elevators open back up
and all these people
pour in and they're like,
they're very excited about themselves.
- Oh well--
- That's how I feel.
- Okay.
Yeah.
- I just felt like
I was on an elevator
with a bunch of people
very excited about themselves.
Now we're different.
We're just very picky and demanding.
And crotchety and can fill
reams of audio with complaints.
- I'm not complaining about
the extremely, you know--
- They seem happier than us.
- Well made-up--
- I'm just saying.
- Athletic teens.
- A lot happier than us.
- But I just made an observation.
I felt like I was like, I
had fast forwarded to some,
in the distant future,
we will colonize Mars
and everyone will wear
matching athletic wear--
- Velour.
- And paint their faces
and pull their hair really tight so that
they can be transported
by the special train
that grabs you by your hair.
You know what I'm saying, it's like,
that would begin to make sense to me.
But it's so, everybody looked the same.
It was very uniform, it was
like this is our uniform.
We are British vloggers.
- Again, it's probably
not a British thing.
- You think it's just people of that age.
- Yeah.
- On the internet.
- Yes, yes, yes.
- Okay.
We are people on the internet now.
- I love the humor.
Let's not forget that.
We made a video with
TomSka and in the middle
of the video I was like, I
just love the way you funny.
You know, I didn't say that.
'Cause that doesn't even make sense
but you know what I mean,
like that was my sense of,
I really enjoy your humor.
- It's the greatest.
- It's the greatest, man.
- It's the greatest humor,
it's so self-deprecating.
And we made it back.
Oh, did I meet J.J. Abrams on the plane?
Perhaps. (chuckles dramatically)
I mean I won't go into it but we're buds.
Rhett was, you know...
I pointed him out when we were waiting
to get on the plane, we
were like sitting there.
- Yeah.
- Pre-flight like
sitting in the airport.
- And then we start walking to our seats--
- That's J.J. Abrams.
He just finished filming
a Star Wars movie.
- It's not just J.J. Abrams.
I mean J.J. Abrams,
this guy is responsible
for the revival of the Star Trek universe.
- Star Wars.
Shows that were on our list.
- He's a brilliant--
- Of our most influential
television, tale-ivision
shows, Alias and Lost.
- What a brilliant entertainer.
Writer, director, producer.
Oh gosh, this dude.
- And your seat was right next to him.
- And I'm like (sighs).
I made up my mind I
wasn't gonna talk to him.
I respected him so much that
I didn't wanna do me to him.
- But it was a 10 hour flight
and you weren't exactly,
you were next to him but--
- Did I look at what was on his phone
throughout the entire flight, yeah.
He played Words With Friends.
He played some other
game I couldn't identify.
He was texting people.
Somebody was like, hey can you talk?
And I was like why am I reading his texts?
That's wrong and I didn't read the rest.
But it was kinda in my
face, I wasn't like craning.
Like he would hold up,
he was kinda leaned back,
and he would hold his, I
don't know if he's nearsighted
or something, he wasn't
wearing his glasses.
He would hold his phone at
like full arms' length away.
- So you could read his texts.
- So that we could both read his phone.
- It's like, Link.
You seeing what I'm seeing here?
(both chuckle)
Yep.
- He hadn't talked to me, and then--
- You talked to him at the end.
- Over the course of the flight,
I was having this internal
dialogue about this dialogue.
And also more importantly,
the dialogue that I was
gonna have with my daughter.
If I told Lily that I
sat next to J.J. Abrams
and I did not speak to him,
she would be very angry.
- Yeah.
- Matter of fact, when I
got home and I was like,
Lily, guess who I met?
And we had a little yes or no game
and she guessed J.J. and
she got tears in her eyes.
Like literally, she was like so, like,
just emotional about the fact
that I met him. (chuckles)
So then I was validated
that I had made up my mind
that when we're getting the
bags and he's about to walk out,
and I noticed that a flight attendant,
I'm not gonna call 'em a stewardess,
came up to him like halfway
through the flight and was like,
this was from another area of the plane
and like crouched down and
talked to him for awhile
and he was most gracious to her.
- Oh super nice guy.
- And so I was like,
I was like J.J., congratulations
on wrapping the shoot,
and he looked at me like,
am I supposed to know you
and I'm like, I just
saw the pictures online
that were posted and he was
like, thanks man, thanks.
And he was like, yeah I'm
really excited about it
and I was like, well,
you're not the only one.
He was like yeah yeah, I'm
just glad that this point,
I was afraid at this
point, you're always afraid
at this point meaning
when you're done shooting
but haven't edited.
You haven't gotten to that stage.
You're not gonna have
everything, he's like,
we got all of it, so he
gave me an assurance.
- It's gonna be okay.
- He had everything he needed.
- J.J. Abrams has got his--
- He's got what--
- Stuff on lockdown.
- He got what he needed.
- It's good to know.
- And I was like you know
what, I'm sure you do, J.J.
And that was pretty much it.
I'm sorry I had to cut off
my conversation with you
in order to turn and talk to him but,
I was kinda in the middle
of our conversation,
I just like whip pan--
- I understood.
- Okay.
- I was glad you initiated with him.
I was glad you waited until
that moment to initiate
with him as well.
Because if you had have done
something to embarrass yourself
early into the flight then it
would have been very awkward
for the rest of the time--
- Right.
- For both of us.
- 'Cause you were next to me.
- Very gracious, very gracious dude.
Very talented.
- Okay.
- Well there it is.
- So that's London, you know,
I'm sure that you have your
opinions about our opinions
and that's what the world's all about.
That's what the internet's about.
- You know what, let
me know, #EarBiscuits,
because I am going back to
London on vacation with Lily.
- And I am later in the year,
both of us will be back in London--
- We are gonna go back.
- In 2019.
- And we are gonna experience
it for, just as tourists.
Not in work mode.
And I'm gonna tread lightly when it comes
to the food but I'm gonna
tread heavy when it comes
to the experience.
I love it, I love it.
- Just gotta make
the right choices, that's all.
You just gotta make the
right choices, no pizza.
- Let me drop a recommendation.
We gotta start teasing
that we do recommendations
at the top so that people
will endure our complaints
until the end so they
can get to this point
and experience what I'm
about to recommend to you--
- Okay.
- And to them.
'Cause it's my week for a recommendation.
♪ Check baby check baby
one two three four ♪
Wreckx-n-Effect is the name of the band.
This is a Rec in Effect.
- Okay.
- This is another song that,
I was having a conversation
with Britton the other
night about Ronnie Milsap.
♪ Smoky Mountain rain keeps on falling ♪
- Yeah, big fan.
- Oh he's great.
He's blind too.
It's just, if you're curious,
he's the blind country music guy.
- I think he was legally blind.
I don't think he was completely blind.
- Well he wears the sunglasses,
if you're trying to picture who he is.
When I dressed up like Lionel
Richie and sang Endless Love
with you dressed up as Diana Ross,
I looked like Ronnie Milsap.
- Yeah, you did.
- So that's who this guy is.
We were talking about him,
talking about how much we loved
him and he was like, well,
we were talking about his
voice and he was like,
well have you heard his
duet with Kenny Rogers?
- Oh.
- I was like no, I haven't.
'Cause Kenny has a signature
voice and he's like,
well, and then we put
it on and I played it.
1987's Make No Mistake, She's Mine.
- Sounds like The Girl
Is Mine Paul McCartney,
Michael Jackson kinda situation.
- It exactly is that.
- About the same year.
- A couple years earlier,
this was originally a Barbra
Streisand, Kim Cairnes song.
But then when they did
their country version,
they changed it from Make
No Mistake, He's Mine
to She's Mine and they
won a Grammy for it.
Incidentally, it was also
performed in a season of Glee, this song.
So you'll have to listen
to it on your own,
I'm not gonna play it for rights issues,
but Make No Mistake, She's Mine,
Ronnie Milsap and Kenny Rogers.
I sat there and listened to it.
I'm getting goosebumps
just telling you about it.
Look at that.
And you listen to it and you tell me
who has the better voice.
That's the question and it's
almost an impossible question.
They both, you think--
- I would say Ronnie Milsap
just based on--
- But then when I heard it,
Kenny starts and he's got that rasp
and it's basically perfection.
And then when Ronnie comes
in, it's smooth, like jazz--
- It's a good mix.
I can imagine.
- I can't believe I'd
never heard this song.
You were going, you're gonna love it, man.
And you might like it too, it's--
- (chuckles) You might.
- The voices.
The iconic country music
voices in one song,
I'll leave it at that.
- If they play Ronnie Milsap
at the Slug and Lettuce,
I might go back.
Just have a drink and
listen to some music.
I take it all back, Slug and Lettuce.
- #EarBiscuits, let us know
what you think about all this.
Thanks for hanging out with
us, for listening to us
and whatever you're
doing in your day, man,
I'm glad we're a part of it.
- Yeah.
- [Link] To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.
(electronic music)